in a war with multiple front lines this
is one of them Sky News has verified
this video filmed yesterday in the
southern Port City of maripol
[Music]
AR
civilians here are caught between the
sea and intense fighting
today Russian and Ukrainian officials
agreed a temporary ceasefire to allow
people to escape from here and the
nearby city of volnovica it was
cautiously welcomed those people willing
to leave these places should be able to
do so now using the humanitarian
corridor
but those who can should continue
fighting on our side to make sure that
this agreement Works regarding the
humanitarian corridors
but within hours the Ukrainian
government posted this message saying
Russia wasn't honoring the ceasefire and
that it was still not safe Russia though
said this was the fault of Ukrainian
aggression and that sanctions by the
West were akin to a declaration of war
looks like everyone is
wanting to achieve an agreement what's
dampling the
optimism is the angry statements
um
the desperate are trying to escape
ruined towns and homes
like billetvertska around 50 miles south
of Kiev
oh
[Applause]
but many have opted to stay tens of
thousands Ukraine says are even coming
back to fight
in this video filmed in the southern
city of Kirsten you can see protesters
draped in Ukrainian Flags
chanting shame they don't back down even
when shots are fired into the air
[Music]
legends from the UK Ministry of Defense
says the rate of Russian strikes has
fallen in the past 24 hours but that
four major cities are encircled by
moscow's troops this video from Booker a
town 20 miles west of Kiev shows what
appears to be Russian military vehicles
blocking roads
foreign
Russia's defense minister released this
video purporting to show a ka-52 attack
helicopter launching anti-tank missiles
at Ukrainian forces in an unidentified
location Ukraine's President says the
only thing that will stop this assault
is Western assistance with aerial
Firepower
but a no-fly zone has once again been
ruled out by the U.S Secretary of State
the only way to actually Implement
something like a no-fly zone is to send
NATO planes into Ukrainian airspace and
to shoot down Russian planes and that
could lead to a full-fledged War
Anthony blinken arrived in Poland today
to meet and thank the groups helping
those who fled
the UN says since fighting started 10
days ago a million people have left
Ukraine the majority have come here to
Poland
some will be able to stay with family or
friends
others are now in temporary shelters
catapulted into crisis
Sky News